so right at the top of this scene
marla grayson uh has to this point been
feeling
pretty pleased with life and business
she has
got her cherry which is the perfect
client the perfect ward someone
fairly able-bodied very able-bodied and
uh likely to live a long and healthy
life that she can
she has maneuvered into care and can
therefore leave them in care leave her
in care
while stripping her of her assets uh
however just prior to the scene muller
has received a visit
an unexpected um
visit that was not in her appointment
diary from a from a rather
uh flashy i would say lawyer played by
chris messina
and then he says that jennifer peterson
is kind of off limits
she goes out to find out exactly who
jennifer peterson is
jennifer how are you feeling
why do i know you i'm your guardian
marla
oh thank god i need help i need my
cell phone to call her so she comes in
she's pretty annoyed because she
realizes she's made a mistake
she has to come under the guise of being
a friendly and
uh reassuring guardian but she's she's
pretty pissed off at this point
jennifer do you know a man named dean
erickson
who what dean dean erickson you know
dean no i don't no he says he works for
you he says he's a he's a lawyer
lawyer does he look expensive
no and i think diane you knew exactly
how you wanted jennifer to look didn't
you in that in this scene
you'd just taken control i think of the
whole look
am i right well i figure as as down
as i can go and i can go pretty far down
in appearance um
that's where she should be just a mess
[Laughter]
[Music]
you're in trouble now everything she
told me
like you can make a call whenever you
want it's not coming true
you know i'll be back to see you soon
and you're going to be very
comfortable here nothing's coming true
so there's suspicion and also
underneath everything there's this a
feeling of hope
and then a feeling of despair because
i hope that my son will come soon
and he'll get me out because you know
he's my son um
and then i'm i'm despairing because he
hasn't come
just you wait
jennifer who are you
so much drugs drugs i
can't think tell me who you are
we sort of knew the shape of the scene
and within it the lines didn't always
follow the same order did they we sort
of
no no followed your
drugged state really we followed where
jennifer
was coming out of her fog or into her
lucid moments
and it strikes me about this scene that
um
we we're both that both characters are
able to act
and that's what comes out is that is
that the jennifer that we meet at the
door
when i take you is very different from
there's this underbelly of jennifer oh
you're a
robber no i'm your guardian
you're my guardian robber tell me who
you are
oh jennifer jennifer tell me
i'm the worst mistake you'll ever make
one of the keys to this scene is that we
for marla
to and any observer in the games room
she has to have body language that
suggests that she is exactly what she
says which is a guardian
paying a formal caring visit to one of
her wards so
her mana her body language her face has
to convey
warmth and empathy and all the all the
things that she actually is weaponizing
you know let me get out of this place
whereas you know the steel has got to
come out in in close quarters only
i suppose that's true that's so hard to
do
and you do it brilliantly i got nothing
to say
listen to me nothing
i control your drugs your food
we could just play off each other
because you are so open
to anything that might happen and that
allows uh
such a freedom in me and in the scene
itself
not you me and i can make things
very bad for you it was a wonderful
thing to be able to do for me
it was delicious and i suppose diane in
this scene we're both
trying to find out who the other one
really is
the other thing about jay's writing is
he never really does a duologue scene
in which you know only one character
wants something he or he's very good at
both characters wanting something from
the scene and that's why the scenes fizz
i think
don't have that little cracker
[ __ ] when rosamund was right there
and i said it to her to her face
um i felt a little that mafioso stuff
just come up at me i'm gonna get you
i don't know how i don't know how it's
gonna work out
but i'm gonna get you how about it
i felt i couldn't get any more miserable
really so
let her threaten me i don't care
it's very powerful that's the thing
about this film is all the way through
you've got this
this uneasy comedy going on and yet
the undertow is is very real and
distressing
yes and that's a very strange balance to
to play and and jay blakeson who wrote
it obviously he's
you know he is a master of his own tone
and without him
i don't think it would have worked when
i watched the movie
i have never seen
the determination the perseverance
and the stamina in a woman
that i saw in rosamund never
and i kept on thinking how is she doing
this
this is all based on truth this was an
article
in the paper this happens
in america yes it does and that's
you know that's what jay jay read an
article
and thought how can i get the biggest
audience for this
terrible thing and it's not to tell it
from the victim's point of view it's to
reverse that
and so deliver something that's
delicious and wicked and fun
yes which then people find that they're
rightly very angry about right
it's underpinned with such um
suffering real suffering
yeah and that is at play in this scene
isn't it you know you've got the
the kind of scene of a of a crime drama
or you know some sort of scene where two
people are trying to
you know get the lowdown on one another
and as i said the undertow
is something very tragic really very
very tragic very truthful and tragic i'm
so pleased we've got to talk about this
scene
so i think it's really interest really
interesting